[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas loin de mes prothèses parce que
quand on a mal on n'a pas le côté oui
j'ai parlé foot et les choix répondent
le prêter ouais
[Musique]
didon cerveau ghana away l'amalgamé
ouais ouais y'a pas moi c'est avoue
enfin je me comprends dit dont on peut
récupérer le ballon
ah non non on peut pas récupérer le
ballon non parce que le petit vient des
violentes et là par un animal sauvage ou
je sais pas quoi mais il y aurait
peut-être les deux yeux crevés
alors je crois que ça va aller loin
s'infecte mes copains on dit donc wayne
morgane elle à l'hôpital un coin mais il
s'est fait toujours partie génitale
les médecins peuvent même pas encore se
prononcer on sait même pas s'il va
pouvoir se reproduire un jour ah ouais
et bien ce serait peut-être pas mal
enfin je me comprends parce que dans la
résidence vous était peu trop nombreux
alors je sais pas si elle chante poteau
ou quoi dans le quartier chez pas je pas
le savoir parce que déjà qu'on a le goût
et les odeurs enfin je me comprends ça
marche les allocations ça paye les
bananes enfin que mes copains tu vas
trop loin a dit dong kwan est ce que je
comprends ma quoi il sait qu'en 45 les
[ __ ] il aurait pu finir le boulot
qu'est ce que dit question qui passionne
pas ce qu'est ce que tu as du plaisir
puisque tu me causerait pas de quoi non
abordant voulons garder nos aînés qui
sont des choix est bon qu'à ça des
chiens de poser à qui courent partout
dans nos résidences ils sont numérotés
non
parce que c'est pas une plus soin de moi
enfin je me comprendre vendredi on
organise un safari avec les voisins
aient pu maintenir anglade fugueur en
bas du parking va falloir l'homme est
ailleurs n'est pas n'a fait que
certaines n'attend pas et puis c'est pas
dimanche coin hein t'as pas mis la
galette et les guirlandes la corrèze
j'ai précisé depuis qu'ils ont coupé la
piste ont fait l'amer ça t'a rendu
nerveux moyens avec ton nom de ton
l'ombre de moucherons la mauvaise de 50
ans maintenant pour haïti fil du temps
en temps faire bouffer de la treille
nature pour dix mois de juin et maousse
costaud
j'étais tout petit avec qui il a gagné
deux maps ou trop conne été jetés
patiner attention moyenne ça va être la
vraie boucherie je te préviens quan et
celle là elle sera pas cacher on y
arrive témoin jeu déployé dinoire
attention et wen
[Musique]